they'll take their swings off the
right-hander trevor richards he's been a
swing man this year for the race see him
eight appearances three starts under his
belt does not have a record yet
5.3 era he's been in 28 innings pitch 39
hits along the way so opponents are
hitting 317 off of him
23 strikeouts nine walks that's a pretty
good ratio a walk
vermont castle so burns at first and
second with one out with severino
stepping in
swinging a ground ball left side fielded
by wendell goes to second out
turn to first by brusso it's a double
play they go around the horn it goes
five to four to three
it is indeed the tech data double play
and
trevor richards able to get out of the
first inning unscathed
and the story around here is the man on
the mound ben mcdonald
local man too bruce zimmer from right
here in baltimore
a graduate of loyola blakeville began
his college career at towson
of course then he transferred over to
university of mount olive where he was
a fifth round pick by the braves traded
over
the kevin gazman deal to baltimore and
boy i tell you what he had a good year
last year between double and triple a
with the orioles 3.21 era 140 innings
pitched
and the rays have two on willie really
has had his issues here of late he
batted four times in the opener and
struck out each and every time swinging
a drive
left field and deep back out of his haze
to the wall it's gone
and willie adamus who has been
struggling
hits a three-run home run to get the
raise off and running
in game two trevor richards to hunter
alberto
fly ball well hit to left to russell
back he's at the wall and this is gone
into the first row of seats for alberto
camden yards giveth and camden yards
take it away
alberto goes deep his third home run of
the year and the orioles are
on the board of the second it's three to
one
zimmerman delivers and the first ball is
swung on and drilled out to deep left
field
way out of here way over the left field
wall and almost to the second deck
a long home run for hunter renfrow it's
reigning baseballs in baltimore
and the rays lead back to four to two
here is ruiz struck out on a high
fastball his first time up
swinging the drive out to right renfro
back nearing the track at the fence it's
going
[Applause]
this one carobs into the right field
seats ruiz with home run number nine
and guess what it's a tie ball game
for a piece as ruiz sends one out and
the orioles level the score
the infield hit from valleca now mullins
delivers here's dj stewart
there's his swing and a ball slash down
the right field line
fair ball in the right field corner
velenka waved around
they send mullins to the plate bro goes
in towards second it's
off of stewart he is there safely he has
got a
two-run double and the orioles have a
six-four lead
a pitch that was up stuart tomahawk
chopped it down the right field line
it allowed for blanket to score mullins
with great speed
comes in from first as steward
pulverizes
a hanging breaking ball low still at
first with two away and that'll leave it
for joey wendell
and there's a shot high and deep to
right and
wendell is going to tie this game
he hit the flagpole joey wendell on a
1-2
pitch belts this one out his third home
run of the year
and just like that the rays are back
even
it's a six six ball game it sets up men
at the corners for the raise
with nobody out now a base hit
the other way here comes crossover the
rays
take the lead on the base hit
by nate lowe who drives in the run
it's a 7-6 ball game run ray's lead
still loaded up for joey wendell left
center field and deep backing up out of
this hayes
he'll make the catch tagging at third is
nate lowe he will rumble home the throw
comes in the third for manny margot
and he is saved we'll talk about your
productive outs it gets a run in
and advances two more and it's nine to
six rays
now one down runners on second and third
infield stays in
there's a swing and a fly ball the left
field this is deep hayes going back
again at the track makes the catch
dang the third is margot he will score
it's a sacrifice fly
by randy arose arena and the razor to
double digits
they lead it 10 to six and it's now two
outs here in the seventh inning swinging
the ground ball right side this should
do it brosto has it
throws the first raceway ray's win ray's
win and for the second consecutive
season
the tampa bay rays are going to the
postseason for the sixth time in team
history
as there are high fives and handshakes
the tampa bay rays
are on for the postseason once again so
john curtis was able to get it done
and the rays picking up their 33rd win
of the season